you have to market your business
otherwise you're gonna end up having to
go back get a job working for somebody
that you hate while you see other people
make big money off of your ideas hi I'm
Evan Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today I'm
answering a question from one of my
newsletter readers named Victoria
Victoria wrote in to say hi Evan out of
your inspiration I started a
kindergarten and a cool daycare of
school in my home area well I'm glad I
could have that impact this is awesome
we opened in June and now have seven
students how do I promote my school
better Victoria this is exciting you
know I love seeing entrepreneurs start
up out of especially my inspiration so
thank you for writing in to let me know
to your question how to promote your
school two things that I have in mind
for you first great job on already
getting those seven students you need to
provide an amazing service for these
guys okay you need to make this the best
kindergarten or daycare program around
because you need the parents to tell
each other word of mouth is so powerful
for an entrepreneur especially when we
don't have huge budgets that won't and
spend on marketing you need the parents
talking about it and it's not good
enough just to provide a good service
you have to go way above and beyond to
get the parents talking about you so
think about what you can add as part of
your program that no other kindergarten
or their daycare program does give the
parents something to brag about because
parents love to talk give them something
for them to say oh well in my
kindergarten or my dear career program
they do this and they do this and they
do this the parents want to brag
parents love comparing their kids you
want to give them that ammunition so
think about it it doesn't have to be
that hard doesn't have to be anything
that cost you a lot of money but think
about ways that you can give the parents
something to brag about so they'll go
and tell their friends about how great a
service you have and pretty soon you'll
be busting at the seams and you need to
think about ways to expand I'm going to
be writing back to say hey I've and now
I'm trying to expand any more ideas I'm
excited I want to hear these success
stories okay the other thing you can do
so beyond that that's great that'll help
especially as you already have students
second is partnerships the
fastest way to grow a business is to
partner with people who already have
your target market so who is already
selling to these moms local businesses
anybody you can think of who already has
a connection to the parents that you're
trying to reach and introduce yourself
try to make a partnership and it can go
both ways
you know it's not going to be a direct
competitor of yours but people who have
related products and services
maybe stores that sell baby products
nannies hospitals whatever it is people
who have your target market already find
a way to introduce yourself partner up
with them when you expose each other to
your clients and if they believe in it
and they talk about you they'll
introduce a huge amount of new business
to you and instead of having to convince
customers one by one by one by one about
how great you are your organization
partner does it for you and you bring a
constant stream of new people into your
business so good luck those are my two
tips for you over there were like crazy
give the parents something to brag about
so they'll drive new traffic for you and
partner up with related companies who
are servicing your target market and
have them help promote you thanks for
watching everybody you liked this video
you know the drill give it a thumbs up
below I love seeing those come in and I
really appreciate it and hey I want to
hear what you have to think I love your
comments on this video and I want to
hear what your questions are for your
business as well please leave in a
comment section below I really do read
every one that comes in and it makes my
morning every time I see them so thank
you and I'll see you on the next episode